this Monday I went to my first ever
Apple event I've never been to an Apple
event before so I don't know what's
gonna happen
I already gets pretty crazy in there
pretty rowdy and here are some things I
learned
first of all I looked a little different
from most people at the event
they play some damn good music at this
thing I feel like this is better than
the club right now I'm the only person
Jam
I'll take this guy Kevin is pretty bad
at drawing a flower but pretty good at
developing software also these people
really like their Game of Thrones HBO
I'm a man Kevin his dog was ready to be
picked up and I'm expecting to get a
call to see what he's ready she's like
okay I'm still a little iffy when it
comes to constant communication you can
read full email thank you okay you know
how much also Kevin his daughter needs
to be a little bit more responsible
here's one coming in from Maddie saying
that she's forgot her key and kept it in
the house I mean he's in the middle of a
presentation girl app developers are a
bit more cooler than you would expect
they're always down a fist bump or a
compliment you on your hat I love your
hat so
however you may have some different
opinions on something which color okay
one space gray and photo boots is still
the best part of a MacBook
also there's now another way for people
to avoid talking about their feelings
and you can even send your heart beat
this is an incredibly intimate way to
tell someone you're thinking about it
also
Shazaam finally got it together I see
the song the album art I can see the
lyrics overall I learned that Apple sits
on a pretty good party with surprises
thrills and a lot of badly drawn
sketches oh and by the way tech bloggers
can be kind of aggressive okay I almost
took a laptop to the head oh excuse me